Welcome back everyone this would be my
spider-man no way home alternate ending and
deleted scenes video there are so many things
that did not make the final cut because this
movie is so big as you'd expect it's kind
of like avengers end game like spider-man
end game and there were so many deleted scenes
from avengers infinity war avengers end game
so no different with spider-man no way home
if you're new to the channel we're doing an
imax giveaway for tickets for the movie all
you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and just leave your favorite moment from the movie
on the video careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen the movie yet because we need to talk about
everything that happened but tom holland revealed
that even though things worked out with their
multiverse story bringing back toby mcguire
andrew garfield as their versions of spider-man as
well as the legacy versions of green goblin doctor
octopus electro sandman and tom hardy's venom from
all their movies the entire third act of the movie
in the ending changed almost every day when they
were working on it that's basically all the events
starting with toby maguire and andrew garfield
being portaled in by ned leeds and mj and then
working with tom holland's mcu spider-man going
full spider-man science bros to fight the sinister
six cure them at the new statue of liberty
their big final battle and the way they
end the fight with tobey maguire's spider-man
stopping tom holland from killing green goblin
in doctor strange performing the second spell so
basically everything involving toby mcguire and
andrew garfield during the film the reason it kept
changing is mostly because of their availability
in sony and marvel people working to get them on
board and figure out exactly what they'd be doing
in all their scenes you'll get your rent when you
fix this damn door so the alternate version of the
ending is really just bigger than just the ending
and it goes hand in hand with all the multiverse
spider verse toby maguire andrew garfield stuff
as well as the sinister six multiverse villains
early on when they had just started figuring
the story out like what it would actually be
before they started filming tom holland said that
the marvel and sony people had come up with an
entirely different group of villains for him to
face in the film a completely different story
that did not involve the multiverse because at
the time they didn't think that they'd be able
to get willem dafoe alfred molina jamie foxx
thomas hayden church reese ephons to come back
and at the time it didn't seem like they would be
able to get tobey maguire or andrew garfield back
like if they hadn't been able to convince
everybody to come back and sign contracts
the whole movie would not have worked so their
backup plan this alternate version of the movie
was to make spider-man no way home a craven
movie they were basically gonna do the story
of craven's last hunt where he almost killed
spider-man successfully like he's on the edge of
death at the end of that story craven literally
buries him in the ground just like aunt may got
buried after her death in the film so the very end
of the film like this actual ending scene of him
getting the new apartment and making his new comic
book accurate spider-man suit based on the classic
cloth one from the comics with the brighter colors
and the new spider-man symbol was still going
to happen they were still trying to get to that
moment like the tag scene of him swinging through
new york city during christmas metaphorically
reborn re-tuned as a friendly neighborhood
spider-man from the comics more ground level was
still gonna happen but the way they dealt with
the mysterio plot was going to be different doctor
strange was still always going to be in the movie
they would have still used a version of the spell
to make people forget that he was spider-man it's
just that the effects of the spell would have
been more contained to the mcu earth and they
wouldn't really dealt with the consequences
of the spell till doctor strange multiverse
of madness whereas we actually see some of the
consequences during the end of the film with the
big purple tears in reality we wouldn't have seen
as much of that happen until doctor strange too
and the spell would not have started pulling
all the multiverse villains from the tobey
maguire and andrew garfield movies into the
mcu even though in the theatrical cut when
we do see the purple tears and those characters
start showing up like the bright blue creatures
from other universes other characters that
know a version of spider-man is peter parker
most of those characters are other spider-man
villains like there's a version of kraven the
hunter there's a classic version of black
cat rhino but this alternate version of the
movie would have mostly just been craven seeing
spider-man docks by mysterio like watching the
broadcast like everybody else on the planet and
then targeting him as the ultimate hunt like the
ultimate challenge and he would have seemingly
successfully killed spider-man but at the end
of the movie doctor strange would have still done
the spell everyone would still have forgotten him
including mj ned leeds all the avengers so they
were always going to take him back to friendly
neighborhood spider-man territory like get rid of
all the tech there was also an alternate version
of the movie where tom holland said that they
focused more on a civil war between spider-man
and doctor strange for a while that aspect of the
story was just a much bigger deal to the plot and
they were going to spend way more time on it but
then all the sinister six multiverse villain stuff
and the toby and andrew stuff started working out
everybody started signing their contracts so they
focused more on the multiverse characters in the
theatrical cut correctly so i think they did the
right thing there because it's already kind of
hard to believe that doctor strange would fight
spider-man and that spider-man would actually
be able to beat him in the theatrical cut the
way they played it it was more like doctor strange
was giving him a chance to prove himself like all
right kid i'm not trying to kill you or anything
the whole joke about him getting reversed loki
stuck above the grand canyon for 12
hours i've been falling for 30 minutes
i have been falling for 30 minutes in reality
doctor strange is powerful enough to have freed
himself from the mere dimension immediately so
he's more like a very annoyed surrogate father
to him the way that iron man got super pissed
at spider-man during homecoming for wrecking the
fairy there's a deleted scene of doctor strange
and wong that you all probably spotted from the
trailers when they're figuring out how to
help spider-man with his mysterio problem
at the very beginning in the theatrical cut
wong says the spell's too dangerous but then
doctor strange argues with him saying that
it's not and then wang just says okay fine
but leave me out of it and it goes to kamar taj
in the trailer version of the scene there was an
alternate version where wong says strange don't
cast that spell is too dangerous and strange says
fine i won't very sarcastically then wong
steps through the portal to kamar taj and
after he's gone strange winks at peter
like he's defying wong's direct orders
strange don't cast that spell
it's too dangerous fine i won't
the funny thing you also probably spotted in
the doctor strange multiverse of madness trailer
is that they actually brought back
that deleted version of the scene
from the spider-man trailer like
it plays right at the beginning
it's too dangerous why we tampered
with the stability of space time
that's just all in service of the idea that doctor
strange and his variants across the multiverse to
make a loki connection with all of kang and his
variants loki and his variants all these doctor
strange variants are doing things to break reality
in their own universes that's why in the doctor
strange trailer baron mordo is saying the greatest
threat is you the greatest threat to our universe
is you
things just got out of hand he's talking about
doctor strange and his variants there was a very
big deleted cameo scene in spider-man noway home
with the younger version of morgan stark played by
lexi rabe from avengers endgame i believe it would
have just been another iron man avengers end game
callback in the way that spider-man far from home
featured a lot of iron man references with skrull
nick fury the disgruntled stark industries
employees like mysterio william ginter riva,
the others that were working with them the edith
glasses and the drones they only briefly mentioned
stark industries a couple times during spider-man
no way home with a special fabricator in the iron
man arc reactor that happy stole and put in his
apartment and when they're being investigated
by damage control they don't mention pepper
potts she's still currently ceo of the company
and presumably during this whole montage when
j jonah jameson is broadcasting all this stuff
they would have also featured a small cameo
scene with morgan stark i'm assuming they cut it
for time mostly because they didn't have gwyneth
paltrow coming back and it would have been weird
to have a scene with their daughter iron man
and pepper pot's daughter and not have pepper
be there herself too and they probably felt that
because of all the doctor strange stuff the tobey
maguire andrew garfield multiverse stuff in the
movie they didn't need more iron man references
in the whole movie just in general is about them
getting rid of all the spider-man tech and making
him more of a ground level friendly neighborhood
spider-man again like comic book spider-man there
was a big deleted scene with tom holland's younger
brother in real life harry holland also during
that jay jonah jameson daily bugle montage at the
beginning of the film when you see spider-man get
that green paint thrown on him in the advanced
suit that was supposed to happen to him after he
stops a mugger on the street in the mugger was
going to be his younger brother harry holland
he stops him from robbing someone but then on the
street he gets mobbed by the mysterio stands and
one of them throws the green paint on him which is
what we actually saw during the montage just the
part with the green paint then talking about some
of the differences in this big final battle here
at the statue of liberty there were versions of
this final battle without toby mcguire or andrew
garfield like there was a point at which they had
the sinister six villains confirmed they'd all
signed contracts but not toby or andrew so that
version of the final battle presumably would have
been doctor strange coming back sooner from the
mirror dimension in fighting the sinister six with
spider-man and there were various points where
they had andrew garfield confirmed coming back
but not toby maguire so toby maguire was like
the last person to sign a contract to come back
so for a while you have to imagine all the scenes
of them together mentoring tom holland spider-man
all the team spider-man science bros scenes
and it just being andrew garfield spider-man
helping him not toby maguire as far as i can tell
though the venom post-credit scene was always what
we saw in the actual film he was always going
to show up for just a little while have like a
funny moment as a tag scene then leave a piece of
the symbiote behind and go back to his universe
he was never supposed to be like a really
huge character or anything like that
and it's a bit of a surprise but i feel like the
actual theatrical cut of the movie that we got
did wind up being the best version of the movie
sometimes you hear about all these deleted scenes
alternate endings post-credit scenes like
all the nova scenes in avengers infinity war
all the charlie cox daredevil scenes that were
supposed to be in the hawkeye series and you're
like oh that would have been so much cooler if we
would have seen those but the theatrical version
of spider-man no way home did wind up being
the best version of the movie which is amazing
i will do more tobey mcguire and andrew garfield
video soon i'm kind of waiting just a little bit
longer because there's still a couple countries
around the world that have not got the movie yet
for some strange reason i know a lot of you are
asking if the timelines of their universes have
changed because they cure the sinister six
villains like does the plot of spider-man 1
2 and 3 in the amazing spider-man movies now end
differently and is andrew garfield's universe the
same universe as the morbius movie because of all
the crazy easter eggs in the trailer so i'll do
videos for those really soon make sure you have
alerts enabled for my channel so you don't miss
those in my full book of boba fett episode 1 video
we'll post next wednesday when they release it
book of boba fett episode is now happening weekly
replacing all the hawkeye episodes congratulations
david carr you're the giveaway winner from my last
big marvel video please email me on the about page
of my channel so i can get your contact details
everyone click here for my full doctor strange
multiverse of madness trailer video and click here
for my spider-man no way home post credits scene
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!